monsieur keddy bonjour merci d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation lors ce
sentiment anti présence américaine a
toujours existé on irak sais pas si
nouveau il est peut-être accentué ces
derniers temps par les événements
récents
oui vous avez tout à fait raison il est
aussi accentué par deux facteurs d'une
part la fin ou en guillemets de dèche de
l'état islamique en irak donc les
irakiens ont moins peur du terrorisme
sunnite et qui était combattue
officiellement par les américains et le
talent donc l'alourdissent d'écouté
daraîche a disparu ou a été largement
défaits donc vous pouvez partir et on
s'occupera du reste
et il yad'autres l'autre facteur c'est
que la situation réellement des services
publics en lien catastrophique avec des
problèmes d'eau potable au sud de l'irak
là normalement ou le tigre et l'euphrate
se rejoignent une région qui est très
fertile et bon imaginez ce que c'est de
ne pas avoir d'eau potable chez soi dans
une région qui est voulait très fertile
et donc les gens ils se disent pas
cessons de faire de la géopolitique de
faire de d'acheter des armements d'être
le terrain de jeu de l'iran des états
unis de turquie et d'autres et occupons
nous des choses du quotidien d'eau douce
est colère populaire et le fait que les
gens descendent dans la rue très très
massivement il ya vraiment une demande
de des gens ont dit s'occuper de nous
après 20 ans de guerre civile et
internationale en irak
monsieur gaby concrètement que pensez
vous est ce que les américains ont
raison de rester aux et en irak
actuellement très sincèrement c'est très
compliqué parce que quand on dit les
américains il ya plusieurs secteurs
segment au sein du gouvernement
américain
vous avez des gens qui sont très sincère
qui vous disent il risque de résurgence
dodge je pense être est vrai que des
irakiens malheureusement ne sont pas
capables de garantir la souveraineté
tout seul hors frontières sont ouvertes
aux quatre-vents notamment roture castro
n'oublie les turquie intérieur a
commencé rhdp est ce qu'on appelle un
site ultra expansionniste qaïda ou d'un
rêve purpose son chemin souvenez-vous de
ce qui s'est passé à mossoul et d'aider
des massacres qui a eu et de l'inca
parlement irakien armée une police pour
défendre son territoire
mais au sein aussi les américains vous
avez des gens qui sont plus cynique et
qui ont envie de 2,2 de faire la guerre
froide avec avec l'iran donc bon la
réponse à votre question et n'est pas
aux états unis et dormira si les
irakiens montrent des s'unissent et
montrent qu'ils sont capables de former
policiers vers mais ce qu'ils n'ont pas
été capables de faire depuis 15 ans à ce
moment là oui les américains partiront
mais là les américains ils jouent sur
les sur les divisions internes des
irakiens comme le font les iraniens les
turcs ou même les les sunnites saoudien
alors on a des manifestations entier
américaines comme celle d'aujourd'hui on
ait également des manifestations
antigouvernementales qui dure depuis
plusieurs mois est ce que en irak
actuellement est en train de vivre un
tournant disons qu'il est dans une chute
libre depuis saddam hussein déjà de son
régime était catastrophique et depuis
2003 ça continue on est dans la chute
libre et dans chaque épisode on découvre
de nouvelles divisions en irak
aujourd'hui avait deux grandes divisions
vous avez une division il ya un rejet du
gouvernement là aujourd'hui par les
séries une partie des du monde chiite
irakien il ya aussi un rejet des
interventions américaines l'intervention
iranienne aussi ce qu'a aussi se méfie
de de l'iran bon de toute façon le grand
souci en irak
il est double il ya d'une part un
gouverneur à l'état qui n'arrive pas
fonctionné pas de police pas de justice
donc pas de sous traiter et ensuite vous
avez des forces politiques qui sont
tellement diversifiée tellement éclaté
quelques qu'aucune force ne peut agir
sur avoir le dernier mot dans chacun à
sa milice son armée privée mais jamais
personne n'arrivait à imposer un
consensus même force et aux autres donc
on est dans une négociation permanente
est bon les gens n'ont pas m'ont
démontré une grande grande bonne volonté
depuis depuis 15 ans depuis que les
saddam est parti monsieur galets merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse rappelle que
vous êtes auteur et spécialiste en
relations internationales